[Applaudissements]
tu me diras de la donne au roi jeudi
quand même quel réalisateur à part de ça
pour voir ce que vous allez dire à des
rockets attend son premier dvd mais non
c'est non mais parce qu'être c'est un
peu comme étant son vaste et là ils
joueraient brute et je sais tout fait
une terrible classique aura
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi des orages ont provoqué la
mort de ce héros mais ce coup attention
sortez pas de chez moi j'ai entendu
orange a fait là c'est un autodafé tu
m'as j'étais en train de s'auto moutou
rsi s'est entraîné mais soyez un peu
plus tard mais quand même
ou cela mais c'est toi pour toi c'est
mon nom vas-y mathieu labadie a les
chatons vahirua vas-y mathieu asie orage
ô désespoir ô vieillesse ennemie neige
donc tant vécu que pour cette infamie
lâchement mois et le grand mère et le
sujet blanchi dans des travaux guerrier
que pour voir en un jour flétrir tant de
lauriers
[Applaudissements]
les acteurs jeudi déjà icaunais sont
taxés pas mal
[Rires]